aquí tenemos un sistema de ecuaciones
tres temas 4g igual a seis y menos seis
temas
igual a 6 hay un montón de maneras para
resolver sistemas de ecuaciones puedes
graficar los puede resolver por
sustitución pero cuando ves los
coeficientes en alguno de los términos
en este caso los coeficientes de las
tres casi se pueden cancelar y digo casi
pues si sumas tres t menos este no se
van a cancelar no va a desaparecer la t
pero si multiplicó la primera ecuación
por dos para obtener seis t entonces si
cuando sumamos las dos ecuaciones se va
a cancelar la t y sólo quedará la g pero
recuerda no se vale que tan solo
multiplique tres t por dos lo que hago
del lado izquierdo lo tengo que hacer
del lado derecho
de esa manera garantizó que no se altera
la ecuación además tengo que hacerlo a
todo el lado izquierdo así es que vamos
a hacerlo vamos a multiplicar toda la
ecuación por 2
tenemos entonces que dos por tres de 4g
es igual a dos por seis todo lo que haga
de un lado lo tengo que hacer del otro
lado nos queda entonces dos por tres de
seis t más dos por cuatro g es 8 g
y esto es igual a 2 por 6 12 en realidad
he escrito la misma restricción la misma
información que tenemos aquí
multiplicada por dos
ahora déjame escribir la segunda
ecuación justo abajo lo voy a hacer en
naranja esto es menos 6 más
es igual a 6 ahora piensa que está
pasando cuando sumamos las dos
ecuaciones básicamente estoy agregando
lo mismo a ambos lados de la ecuación de
arriba o puedes verlo como si
estuviéramos agregando lo mismo a ambos
términos de la ecuación de abajo ya que
la otra ecuación es una igualdad menos
seis temas que es igual a seis así es
que si agregó seis del lado derecho
estoy agregando la misma cantidad del
lado izquierdo por eso lo podemos hacer
sumemos las dos ecuaciones del lado
izquierdo estos términos se cancelan
para eso multiplicamos dos por tres este
para que se cancelarán seis y menos seis
y nos queda ocho gemas que 9 g que es
igual a 12 618 ahora dividiendo entre 9
ambos lados de la ecuación 9 entre 9 se
cancela y nos queda que igual a 2 ya
hemos encontrado el valor de g
podemos sustituir arriba para encontrar
el valor de t en cualquiera de estas dos
ecuaciones usemos la segunda ecuación
tenemos que menos 6 t más g
acabamos de encontrar el valor de g - 6
t más 2 esto es igual a
6 ahora voy a restar 2 a ambos lados de
la ecuación de estos dos del lado
izquierdo y 2 del lado derecho y no
resulta 2 más menos 2 se cancelan y nos
queda tan solo menos 6 de que es igual a
6 menos 2 que es igual a 4 dividimos
ahora entre menos 6 dividiendo entre
menos 6 ambos lados del lado izquierdo
se cancelan estos términos y nos da
igual a menos 4 sextos o lo que es lo
mismo menos dos tercios y ya hemos
concluido ya encontramos los valores de
tg que cumplen con las dos ecuaciones
sólo vimos que cumplen la de abajo para
tener la certeza de que cumple la de
arriba vamos a sustituir estos valores
en la ecuación de arriba esto es 3 x
menos dos tercios el valor de t más 4
por el valor de g
más 4 por 2 ahora esto es menos 2 estos
3 se cancelan más 4 por 28 menos dos más
8 es igual a 6 si es el valor que está
planteando la ecuación así es que estos
dos valores definitivamente cumplen con
las dos ecuaciones